Yeah,
when I was in the Congress,
I would have dinner every night because
I didn't have a family and uh,
there were other members of Congress who
didn't have their families there and we
went out and had dinner.
Today I'm told it's a rarity to have
people who are of a different parties
that is to say Democrats having dinner
with Republicans and vice versa.
And that's bad.
That's very,
very bad for me.
It's the idea that politics have taken
such hold that it bars,
friendships.
It's worse today than it was then.
And the reason is very simple.
We were then the only city asking for
special help that I can recall from the
congress,
uh,
from the state legislature.
Whereas today,
almost every city in America has the
financial problems that we do on a
lesser scale or something,
be on a higher scale.
So I believe that the current mayor,
Mike Bloomberg,
was doing a magnificent job as problems
that were greater than mine.